i've been following forbes
ever since a chinese china investment
company
bought forbes okay they own 95
of forbes a hong kong-based investment
company bot forbes
forbes has historically been a what a
pro-capitalism pro-freedom pro-america
magazine i don't know if you've been
following their post they're like six
years cool
i don't read the fortune magazine but i
will go forbes we subscribe to forbes we
don't subscribe to fortune right steve
forbes yeah that's right now when you
look at it
now when you look at it yesterday tom
made such an interesting comment he says
i said why the hell is forbes
supporting some of these comments that
hey socialistic ideas and
edifying and building up certain
characters they would have never built
up six years ago seven years ago right
then you look at it 95 percent
they own five percent they own he says
china would like
americans to believe socialism is good
while they go in a complete different
direction
they don't care whether it's good or not
they just care that it divides america
i don't know if there's truth behind it
or not all i'm saying is the fact that i
think it's more fundamental
they are u.s politicians are playing the
short game china is playing a long 100
and china's like we're going to use
capitalism quietly
in a communist regime we're going to
employ capitalism
to overtake the united states and we're
going to encourage socialism in the
united states so that we can weaken it
so it's important really brilliant i
agree with you by the way
hey taiwan is not a 70
70 70-year uh grudge match on the make
good
that they think it's their territory you
know what taiwan is
semiconductors it's an enhanced market
share play
on semiconductors because if they
assimilate that they get more market
share on semi they get more market share
on uh textile manufacturing there is a
ton of stuff that you look there
they want to assimilate this yeah it's
political and yeah they got the planes
flying overhead and this kind of
militaristic and stuff
but really what this is this is market
share of western manufacturing
and and it is so targeted and the the
chinese
state has been pouring money into
into domestic semiconductor
manufacturers in
on the mainland and they fully intend to
have between
taiwan and china they fully intend to
control the world's
semiconductor supply while biden's like
well we'll we'll consider 50 billion
dollars and i'm like yeah good luck with
that
yeah i mean it's it's good luck with
that what do they control right now the
production of any pharmaceutical
industry is coming out of china it's a
good you hear
80 percent some say 60 percent that's a
big number semi-con
what else are they controlling
telecommunications
huawei's huawei's got a third of
the world's telecommunication equipment
is one con
one company huawei and they they're
at the forefront of robotics because
they have to be because their one child
policy is backfiring so their population
is beginning to shrink
so but they've known this they've known
this for a long time they they see the
data
so they're at the top of robotics they
get the mic a little closer audience is
saying they can't hear
good so they're at the top of the
automation chain because they know they
have to replace
their own people so and that puts them
at the front of
artificial intelligence and think of the
control that they can have
think of the control that they can have
over the global economy
germany has tighter economic ties with
china than germany has with the united
states
because they export so much to china and
when you think about world war ii i know
it's a long time ago
but the world is split
along lines and they're always economic
lines
and are you allied with china who
butters your bread
or the united states because they've
always been your ally your friend
traditionally
in a post-world war ii regime so but
again
money talks and your third story
no the worlds are worse i'm limited to
two today i'm working on myself
i believe the world is at war we just
don't see it that way and right now we
have producer supplier wars and the only
difference is we don't have a bunch of
poor serfs with pitchforks
being led by the knights as one king
fights another king
but we are in the middle of producer
supplier wars on a global basis and we
just don't
understand or see it that way i'm going
to throw a statistic out there that's
going to give you an idea of how much
america has changed
okay when the boys went off to fight
world war
ii all right they were leaving a country
that had been
decimated by the great depression they'd
seen
they grew up in the roaring 20s and the
average age
of a gi in world war ii was their early
20s so
they they they enjoy the early the the
roaring 1920s
heyday when they were children and then
through their teenage years when they're
so
impressionable they're in the great
depression they come back
and world war one veterans they gave a
train ticket and 50 bucks
and there was awful unemployment among
world war one
veterans shame on the country staying on
the country
the politicians when they were coming
back said we're not going to do that to
our veterans
we're going to take care of our veterans
they came back
part of the gi bill we had the biggest
college
acceptance we had the best best
best birth rate in the world the baby
boomers
homeownership went through the housing
was massive but this was all va
and this was this was paying to go to
college and this was this is assistance
getting into homes
there was a huge aspect of the gi bill
that was for unemployment
only 20 of those funds were tapped the
boys came back and they refused to take
the government's money because they
loved their country
they want it to work and they wanted to
work for it and they wanted to get in
if they were going to get help they were
going to get help getting educated not
sitting on their ass and look at where
we are today by comparison
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye